HERE.
SEE YOU ALL IN CALIFORNIA.
♪ ♪
>> COVID IS DANGEROUS.
IT IS LETHAL.
IT IS A BIT LIKE THE BEEF THAT
NOTORIOUS B.I.G. USED TO RAP
ABOUT.
GUARANTEED TO BE IN ICU.
>> Greg: AND I SEE YOU MAKING
A DASH OUT OF YOURSELF.
♪ ♪
[APPLAUSE]
SO I WAS TRYING TO THINK IF
THERE'S ANYTHING PERHAPS WORSE
THEN OUR PULLOUT FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
AT FIRST, SAIGON POPS INTO YOUR
HEAD.
BUT COMPARED TO THIS THAT NOW
LOOKS LIKE A ROCKET'S DRESS
REHEARSAL.
I DID IN FACT FIND SOMETHING
WORSE THAN THE AFGHANISTAN CUT
AND RUN.
IT'S THE PRESIDENT'S DEFENSE OF
IT.
>> STILL A LOT OF PANDEMONIUM
OUTSIDE THE AIRPORT.
>> BUT LOOK, NOBODY IS GOING TO
BE KILLED RIGHT NOW.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG ABOUT
THAT, BUT NOBODY IS BEING KILLED
RIGHT NOW.
A COUPLE THOUSAND A DAY, IT'S
INCREASING.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THOSE PEOPLE
OUT.
>> BUT WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
PICTURES, WE'VE SEEN THE
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE PACKED INTO A
C17.
WE'VE SEEN AFGHANS FALLING --
>> THAT WAS FOUR DAYS AGO, FIVE
DAYS AGO.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES THAT EVEN
MEAN?
IT WAS TWO DAYS PRIOR, NOT FOUR.
OF COURSE, I BLAME THAT RACIST
MATH.
WHO DOESN'T LOSE TRACK OF TIME
WHEN YOU ARE IN HIDING?
AND AS FOR NO ONE IS BEING
KILLED RIGHT NOW, IF JOE SETS
THE BAR ANY LOWER I WILL BE ABLE
TO DRINK IT.
SO IT'S TIME ONCE AGAIN FOR...
>> GREAT JOB THERE JOE.
>> Greg: SO YEAH, JOE SAT DOWN
AND INTERVIEW -- GEORGE WAS
STANDING ON A MILK CRATE.
SO DOES THE CHAOS NO LONGER
MATTER BECAUSE IT WAS, AS HE
POINTED OUT, AND CORRECTLY FOR
FIVE DAYS AGO?
DID YOU GET THE DATE
DELIBERATELY WRONG CONSIDERING
THE INTERVIEW WAS PRETAPED.
DOES EVEN KNOW WHERE HE IS?
WE HAVEN'T SEEN A LEADER THIS
FALLEN ASLEEP AT THE WHEEL SINCE
TED KENNEDY.
WHAT A STRANGE, NONSENSICAL
ANSWER.
IS HE REALLY THIS INCOMPETENT OR
DID HE INHALE TOO MUCH OF THAT
SPRAY TAN?
BUT EVERY TIME, EVERY TIME YOU
THINK JOE BIDEN IS BAD, REMEMBER
WHAT CANADA HAS.
>> IT IS EXACTLY THE EXAMPLE OF
THE KINDS OF THINGS YOU NEED TO
DO TO COUNTER THE C SESSION AND
TURN IT INTO A SHE HUFF AND
CALVARY.
>> Greg: HE REALLY IS FULL OF
SHEET.
APPARENTLY THE U.S.'S EXPORTING
WOKE STUPIDITY.
THE TALIBAN HAS TAKEN MORE
QUESTIONS THAN JOE BIDEN.
AND THEN THERE IS THIS PAIR.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE IS
SAYING THIS DEPENDS ON DIPLOMACY
WITH THE TALIBAN.
>> WELL, LET ME ADD SOMETHING
HERE, ALAIN.
WE'VE GOT A COUPLE OF ENTRY
CONTROL POINT SET UP.
A NORTH ONE, A EASED ONE, AND A
THIRD ONE AT ABBEY GATE.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY MOUNTED WITH
OFFICERS, MARINES.
>> Greg: WHY IS EVERYONE
ACTING LIKE IT'S THEIR FIRST DAY
ON THE JOB?
THEIR ENTIRE JOB IS TO PROTECT
AMERICAN CITIZENS, YET THEY ARE
MORE SCARED OF DEPENDING ON THE
DEMOCRATIC LEFT.
HE DOESN'T PUT THE MILLI AND
MILITARY.
JUST LET THAT MARINADE.
IN DEFENSE OF THE GENERAL, NONE
OF THIS WAS IN ANY OF ROBIN
D'ANGELO'S BOOKS ON HOW TO BE AN
ANTIRACIST.
IT SOUNDS LIKE JOE THINKS WE
SHOULD OF GOTTEN OUT A LONG TIME
AGO.
>> IT'S ON FLICK YOU SHOULD'VE
GOTTEN OUT A LONG TIME AGO.
>> WE SHOULD HAVE.
>> AND ACCEPT THE IDEA IT WAS
GOING TO BE MESSING A MATTER
WHAT.
>> WHAT WOULD BE MESSY?
>> GETTING OUT WOULD BE MESSY NO
MATTER WHEN IT OCCURRED.
>> Greg: IT MAY BE HE HAS
RIGHT.
BUT HE COULD HAVE TRIED TO MAKE
IT A LITTLE LESS MESSY.
JOE SAYS WE ANTICIPATED ALL OF
THAT.
BUT I WONDER IF THE PEOPLE
CLINGING FROM THE SIDE OF THE
PLANE WERE MADE AWARE OF THAT.
HE SOUNDS LIKE PEE-WEE HERMAN
AFTER FLYING OVER HIS HANDLEBARS
DECLARING "I MEANT TO DO THAT."
I GUESS THE ONLY SAFE AND
ORDERLY EXIT THE PRESIDENT COULD
MUSTER WAS THE ONE DIRECTLY
AFTER HIS FIRST PRESS CONFERENCE
TO FLEE TO CAMP DAVID.
THE REAL SHOCKER IS THAT IN
AFGHANISTAN IT TOOK 20 YEARS TO
MAINTAIN AND IT FELL FASTER THAN
BIDEN IN A STRONG WIND.
ITS "GUTFELD!" FOREIGN POLICY
101.
THE FIRST THING YOU NEED TO
FIGURE OUT IS HOW TO GET THE
HELL OUT OF IT.
THE GETAWAY CAR IS PRIORITY
NUMBER ONE.
FIRST THING YOU DO IS LOOK FOR
THE EXIT.
AND A GOOD METH DEALER, RIGHT
KAT?
AND NOW WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS THERE.
AND WE CANNOT GET THEM OUT, EVEN
FRANCE IS SENDING IN TEAMS TO GO
DOOR-TO-DOOR.
FRANCE!
THE HOME OF MINDS.
SO THIS MOMENT SUCKS, BECAUSE
THE WHOLE ENTIRE THING SUCKS.
PEOPLE WERE MAKING BILLIONS OFF
THE WAR.
AS POINTED OUT BY JOURNALIST
MATT TAIBBI, THE SPECIAL
INSPECTION GENERAL FOUND 44% OF
66 BILLION AND EXPENSES EXAMINED
WAS LOST TO FRAUD AND WASTE.
IF THE COST OF THE WHOLE WAR WAS
TOO CHILLING, THE WHOLE AMOUNT
LOST MAY BE 600 BILLION.
SELECT CAKE AT A NURSING HOME
BIRTHDAY BASH, EVERYBODY GOT A
PIECE.
EVERYBODY EXCEPT FOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO RISKED THEIR LIVES
THERE.
NICE TRY, MAYBE NEXT TIME.
VETERAN DARRELL OWEN SAID IT
WELL.
"THE U.S. PROVIDED THE LEVEL OF
STABILITY TO AFGHAN LINES FOR
TWO GOOD GRADES TRYING TO REDUCE
THE RISK OF TERRORISM IN OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY WERE GIVEN BACK TO THE
TALIBAN WITH BARELY A WHIMPER."
IT'S NO SURPRISE ACCORDING TO A
POLL THAT 71% SAID THIS DEBACLE
WAS A REASON FOR PERSONAL
SADNESS.
BUT WHO KNOWS, MAYBE THE TALIBAN
HAS CHANGED.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE TALIBAN
HAS CHANGED?
>> NO.
LET ME PUT IT THIS WAY, I THINK
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH A
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS ABOUT, DO
THEY WANT TO BE RECOGNIZED BY
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN A LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT?
I'M NOT SURE I WOULD'VE
PREDICTED THAT, NOR YOU OR
ANYONE ELSE, THAT WHEN WE
DECIDED TO LEAVE THEY WOULD
PROVIDE SAFE PASSAGE FOR
AMERICANS TO GET OUT.
>> Greg: THAT'S A RELIEF, NO
ONE PREDICTED A SAFE PASSAGE
FROM TALIBAN.
BUT IF THAT'S THE CASE, YOU ARE
SAYING IT COULD HAVE BEEN FAR
WORSE, BUT WE GOT LUCKY FROM THE
KINDNESS OF MURDEROUS STRANGERS.
I PUT MORE PREP INTO AN ANIMAL'S
ARE GREAT SEGMENT THEN OUR
LEADERS DID TO GIVE CITIZENS AND
ALLEYS IN AFGHANISTAN A SAFE
EXIT.
WHAT IF THE TALIBAN HAS CHANGED?
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEIR NEW
LOOK.
>> WE ARE GETTING THE PUTIN BACK
TOGETHER.
TALIBAN 2.0.
THIS IS NOT YOUR GRANDFATHER'S
TERROR NETWORK, WE KILLED HIM
YEARS AGO.
WE STILL THINK WOMEN ARE
INFERIOR.
BUT NOW WE USE THE RIGHT
PRONOUNS BEFORE WE KILL YOU.
SEE?
AND OUR LOCAL OFFICES ARE ALWAYS
OPEN.
AND WE PROMISE NEVER TO GO TO
DOOR TO DOOR LOOKING FOR YOU.
>> WE'VE BEEN HEARING MESSAGES
WITH FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING
THAT THE TALIBAN AND THEIR
FIGHTERS HAVE GONE HOUSE TO
HOUSE.
ARE YOU DENYING THOSE
ALLEGATIONS?
>> YES, I TOTALLY DENY THEM.
>> THEY WON'T CENSOR IT BECAUSE
WE DON'T CRITICIZE ELECTION.
DON'T FORGET TO SMASH THAT LIKE
BUTTON LIKE THE HEAD OF AN
INFANT.
WARNING?
TALIBAN 2.0 CANNOT PROVIDE THE
SAFETY OF LGBTQ, WOMEN, OR
ANIMALS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WE'VE GOT PROBLEMS.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE NEW
AFGHANISTAN.
IT'S THE OLD BIDEN.
HE'S DEFTLY NOT AWAKE.
LET'S LOOK AT TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
IF SHE WERE A RESTAURANT, ALL
SHE WOULD BE SERVING -- AMANDA
MILLIE HAS.
HE WENT TO HARVARD AND YELLED,
BUT DON'T LET THAT FOOL YOU.
HE'S ACTUALLY SMART.
IS LIKE A GLOW STICK, BRIGHT,
FUN, AND SEEN ON THE GROUND AT A
RAVE.
KAT!
AND WHEN HE WALKS TO WORK,
JANICE DEAN REPORTS THE WEATHER
IS OVERCAST.
THE NWA, TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AMANDA, WHAT YOU MAKE
OF THIS MESS?
>> WELL, IT'S KIND OF SO DARK
THAT IT'S HARD TO EVEN TRY TO
HAVE A SENSE OF HUMOR ABOUT IT.
BUT YOU'VE DONE A GOOD JOB.
THAT WAS WELL DONE.
I MEAN, THE THING ABOUT IT IS
THAT COMING FROM HAVING WORKED
THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE
WHITE HOUSE, IT'S A REALLY DARK
THING TO LOOK AT, BECAUSE THEY
ARE RIGHT THAT IT'S A
COMPLICATED SITUATION AND THERE
IS NO GOOD TO LEAVE.
BUT THERE'S NO WAY OUR
ADMINISTRATION WOULD'VE LET THAT
HAPPEN.
THE THING THAT I THINK PEOPLE
GET CONFUSED ABOUT IS WHY PEOPLE
GET SO ANGRY AND FREQUENTLY
POINT TO THE WOKE-IS ON.
CERTAINLY OUR CURRENT
STATE DEPARTMENT OVER DOING
THEIR JOB.
MOMENTS LIKE THIS ARE WHY WE
NEED THEM TO BE GOOD AT THEIR
BASIC JOB.
THEIR MOST BASIC FUNDAMENTAL JOB
IS TO GET AMERICANS OUT OF
HARM'S WAY AND TO NOT CONDUCT
OURSELVES IN A WAY THAT IS THIS
EMBARRASSING ON THE WORLD STAGE.
AND PROJECTS THIS MUCH WEAKNESS.
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY
FRUSTRATING.
I THINK THAT'S GOTTEN LOST.
I THINK IT'S SOMETIMES EASY TO
JOKE ABOUT IT LIKE YEAH, THEY
ARE NOT -- THEY DON'T HAVE THE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO GET OUT
OF AFGHANISTAN IN THE WHITE
FRAGILITY BOOK, WHICH IS TRUE.
BUT THE FRUSTRATING THING IS YOU
ARE LIKE, AND YOUR LITTLE
PROGRAMS.
ADD YOUR EONS OF NGOs DOING
FEMALE BEAD MAKING
ENTREPRENEURSHIP PROGRAMS AFTER
YOU FIGURED OUT THE BASICS.
>> Greg: I'VE ONLY KNOWN
SOMEBODY WHO'S WRITTEN A BOOK
ABOUT WOKE-ISM.
THIS IS WHY WHEN PEOPLE DISMISS
THAT WOKE-ISM ISN'T A BIG DEAL.
IT IS A BIG DEAL BECAUSE IT
REPLACES SOMETHING.
IT TOTALLY DOES.
IT REPLACES AMERICAN FORTITUDE.
I THINK THERE'S EXACTLY ONE WAY
THAT JOE BIDEN COULD HAVE
PREVENTED THE SITUATION FROM
HAPPENING.
IT IS A CREDIBLE THREAT TO THE
TALIBAN THAT WE WILL COMPLETELY
ANNIHILATE YOU IF YOU MESS
AROUND WITH OUR EXIT FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
AND IF YOU DID THAT, THEY WOULD
NOT HAVE MESSED AROUND.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE GONE FOR
KABUL.
BUT JOE BIDEN COULDN'T DO IT.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE HE'S OBSESSED WITH SELF
CRITICISM THE UNITED STATES.
EVEN THE TALIBAN KNOWS HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE MORAL STANDING
TO BACK UP THAT THREAT.
SO THAT IS WHY THEY WENT FOR IT.
I THINK THAT'S THE WAY THAT
WOKE-ISM DISRUPTS AMERICAN ON
THE GLOBAL STAGE IS IT REDUCES
OUR MORAL STANDING TO USE
EXTRAORDINARY FORCE, PRECISELY
WHEN WE NEED IT MOST.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF IT.
I ALSO THINK IT'S INCOMPETENCE.
IF YOU ARE JOE BIDEN, WHY
WOULDN'T YOU GO INTO WINTER?
WE HAVE FOOTBALL SEASON AMERICA.
THE TALIBAN -- THEY HAVE THIS
THING.
FIGHTING SEASON.
IT IS SUMMER.
SO GUESS WHAT?
IN WINTER IT IS GOLD.
THEY HAVE SNOW.
AND SAID HE WANTS THE SYMBOLISM
OF DOING IT BEFORE 9/11.
NOW IF THE SYMBOLISM OF THE
TALIBAN FLAG FLYING ON THE TOP
OF THE U.S. EMBASSY ON THE 20TH
ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE, AND IT WAS
ALL TO BAKE IT BEFORE A DATE.
AND THEN YOU CHOOSE THE DATE AND
YOU TO EVERYBODY THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND YOU DO IT WHEN
THEY FIGHT -- IT'S A BIT STRANGE
THAT THEY HAVE A FIGHTING
SEASON.
>> WE ALL KIND OF THOUGHT OF A
FIGHTING SEASON.
[LAUGHTER]
LITERALLY, TWO OR THREE DAYS A
WEEK WHEN I'M HOME.
IT'S LIKE...
[LAUGHTER]
SPEW ON YEAH.
>> OH, JOE.
I GET IT.
IT'S HARD TO ADMIT WHEN YOU ARE
WRONG.
WE NEED TO RESPECT HER BOOTS,
BUT WE'VE GOT TO GET RID OF THE
SUITS.
IF THERE'S ANYBODY WAS THINKING
ABOUT NOT VOTING THIS YEAR,
IF -- THERE SHOULD BE A RECORD
NUMBER OF VOTES WHEN THE SENATE
AND THE HOUSE IS UP.
BECAUSE HOW IS ANY
ADMINISTRATION...
I MEAN, I'M NOT A ROCKET
SCIENTIST, BUT I WOULD'VE KILLED
OUR SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM.
YOU REALIZE THE TALIBAN IS NOT
ONLY PUSHING PROPAGANDA BUT ALSO
USING IT TO FIND WHERE PEOPLE
ARE HIDING, THAT FLAG ON THE
BUILDING EVERYWHERE.
THEY ARE GETTING WORLD
RECOGNITION.
BUT YET IF YOU SAY ABOUT THING
ABOUT SOMEBODY OR IF YOU WERE IN
THE FIFTH GRADE AND SAID THE
WRONG THING, YOU ARE CANCELED OR
WHATEVER.
BUT HERE'S A PLATFORM OF PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY DYING.
WE ARE SEEING IT ON THE STREETS,
GETTING TEXT MESSAGES AND
MESSAGES FROM ALL AROUND THE
WORLD HEARING ABOUT PEOPLE BEING
SHOT ADS.
AND ALWAYS GOTTEN SO FAR IS A
SCATHING EMAIL.
WE SENT A SCATHING EMAIL.
NOT WORKING, GREAT POINT.
HOW ABOUT, YOU KNOW, I GET IT.
MAYBE JUST SEND A VIDEO OF THE
BOMB THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DROPPED.
MAYBE SEND THAT OR SAY, YOU
KNOW, HE'S A PHONE CALL AWAY.
WHATEVER.
BECAUSE THERE WAS A TIME HE
DIDN'T LIKE WHAT HE SET ON
TWITTER SO HE TOOK THEM OFF.
BUT HIS FOREIGN POLICY, EVERY
ONE OF THOSE COUNTRIES FOUGHT
BEFORE THEY STOPPED.
NOW THEY ARE JUST LIKE OUR
BORDERS.
IT'S OPEN SEASON AND THEY ARE
LITERALLY POSTING WHILE THEY DO
IT.
THAT IS SO ARROGANT AND
CONFIDENT THEY ARE BASED ON THE
SPINELESS ADMINISTRATION.
>> THEY NEED TO SEND A PICTURE
OF WHAT THEY DID -- WHAT WE DID
TO SOLOMONIC.
>> Greg: WHAT I MISS IS
READING ANY OF CHRISSY TEAGAN'S
TWEETS ABOUT THE TALIBAN.
THERE'S A BIG EMPTY SPACE.
>> I THINK SHE MIGHT'VE BEEN
ABLE TO SOLVE THIS.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: HER WITHERING WHICH.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I FOR ONE WAS VERY SHOCKED TO
HEAR BIDEN SAY THAT HE DOESN'T
THINK THAT THE TALIBAN IS
KILLING PEOPLE, BECAUSE I'VE
SEEN THE VIDEOS AND NOT A MASK
INSIGHT.
HAVE YOU NOTICED THAT?
THEY ARE ALSO NOT USING THEIR
PLATFORM TO ENCOURAGE
VACCINATION.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.
>> SO MURDERERS -- I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S SO GROSS TO WATCH SO MANY
OF THESE THINGS ON SO MANY
LEVELS AND NOT LEAST OF ALL THAT
NEWS CONFERENCE WITH THE GENERAL
COMPLAINING ABOUT ERRONEOUS
REPORTING AFTER THE YEARS OF
[BLEEP] THAT THEY FED US ABOUT
THIS WAR PUTTING PEOPLE IN
HARM'S WAY.
CRY ME A RIVER.
SHUT UP.
>> Greg: ONLY ONE [BLEEP] FROM
C.A.T. TODAY.
YOU GET TWO MORE FOR THE REST OF
THE SHOW